[Music]
on today's show we have a different show
we talked to a husband and a father
who's experienced unspeakable tragedy
with his wife and with his kids and we
help him pick up the pieces
figure out the next steps that he can do
in his heart and in his home stay with
us
[Music]
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john deloney's show we talk
about relationships and mental health
and life and just the
bonkers world that we live in
friends james and kelly are here with me
and we're so glad that you joined us on
this podcast and on this youtube show
literally there's a trillion other
places you could be and we're glad that
you came over to hang out with us today
we are glad that you are
here
so hey i always tell people hey send me
a follow-up email how this how your
world's going shoot me a letter give us
a call let us know and we get those from
time to time um not as often as i would
like but we do get them sometimes people
are upset with me sometimes people um
actually that's really rare kelly we got
like one of those right just one
yeah we don't get a ton but we've we've
gotten a few more lately you'll be
hearing a couple more of these
they don't like me
no that's just james and i but the other
people they do
so this one came in um jane is what it
says this is jane formerly of louisville
kentucky who called last december
because my husband wanted to transition
to be a woman
this thursday our divorce goes before
the judge in kentucky
chris moved to hawaii and is fully
leaning into his transition and we
relocated to my hometown of tampa
florida in april
it's been hard
the hardest part is that chris is
reckoning or revoking the friendship we
had which is all we had
and what got us through the last four
years
now chris is turning the tables on me
saying i'm dumping him
i'm dumping her
i'm dumping everything
it's all very frustrating and i'm
grieving losing my friend even more than
the final death of the marriage
now chris is saying we never had
anything in common anyway even though
we've been friends since we were 14.
just wanted dr john to know that his
advice has been so helpful to me to make
these tough decisions the final straw
was one on the show the other day dr
john said that kids growing up in a home
with negative vibes
would affect them and they would absorb
it
well later that night i caught myself
making a snide bitter jaded comment
about a cute married couple on hgtv my
daughter got upset and started crying
i knew right then that we had to end the
marriage so i could stop being bitter
because at this point i was choosing
that path and i want to my daughter to
grow up in a clear and bright and happy
vibes home
thank you
so number one man just the heartbreak
surrounding this whole thing i know this
has been hard on everybody in this
relationship um and if you go back and
listen to the call i'm putting the show
notes when the original call was back in
the day and that way you can just go
click and find it
um
this is a tough call they uh this couple
have been working through this for a
long long time
and they had not had much of a marriage
as much as a really close friendship
and um then things got sideways or
ultimately they they're just appeared at
the end of this sentence
but i wanted to point out a few things
in this number one jane thank you so
much for writing back letting us know um
sometimes not sometimes often
um these shows are just in a vacuum for
me so i get to spend ten or eleven or
nine or seven intimate moments with
somebody then it's just gone into the
ether
and i wonder sometimes what's what's
going on
um second thing is
man this is heartbreaking
it's heartbreaking you lost your best
friend you lost your husband
and now you've recognized that your
daughter's absorbed this too and that
she is um
taking your bitterness and it's encoding
in her dna literally
and so i know this has just been a hard
season hard several years for everybody
involved and the challenge that chris
has been going through
um your former husband has been
wrestling with this stuff and just how
hard that's been for everybody
and now you're literally across the
world from your best friend from your
partner of so many years and just tough
but i want to
say a couple more things
the first one is this you mentioned now
chris is saying that we never had
anything in common anyway even though
we've been friends since we were 14.
often when we get to a place where we've
got to make a final call whether that is
the marriage is over or i'm leaving this
job or i'm not going to that restaurant
anymore or something small like i'm not
using
that um
yard guy anymore
we often are so unsettled uncomfortable
in
the hurt of the end of a relationship
with anybody for anything that we made
this is our decision that we are putting
a period into this sentence
that we often make ourselves feel better
by
dumping on
those other relationships
so you know we quit a job and we go take
another job whether it's a good one or a
little bit worse but it's closer to
family further away it's so easy to cast
that former job in a negative light well
i didn't even like working there anyway
they're crazy they like make you do the
it was fine when they were paying you
you know it was great when things were
good it's when something else came along
or they let you go they fire you and
we look back and go well i didn't even
like him anyway
especially this happens with
relationships when people have been
dating a long time they've been married
for a long time and they get to the end
and they turn back and they just
look back and burn everything
reverse in reverse
man i'm so glad i'm not there anymore
they used to smack every time they would
eat dinner and it threw me crazy i'm so
glad to be out of that whatever it
happens to be
so
if you've just had your heart broken if
someone has just left you if someone has
just upended your world if you've just
lost your job fill in the blank
and somebody says
now he's saying we never had anything in
common
anyway
even though we've been for instance 14.
rest assured that that's part of
somebody who's hurting and trying to
grieve and you're just a casualty of
that grief you did have a lot in common
you've been friends for years and years
and years and years and years have a
child together
you had a life together you shared
laughs together you shared grief
together
you went to performances together you
were intimate there was a life there
and often when we look back and say you
know we never have anything in common
anyway you feel crazy because you think
i i thought we did
i thought those laughs were real i
thought that sadness and heartbreak was
real
it was it was i thought that we had a
good working relationship together and i
know that person wants to quit now or we
had to cut them loose but all these
negative things they're saying about us
in the press or at home or with through
mutual acquaintances or mutual
colleagues
i thought we things were good they were
they were so the challenge here is
twofold number one if you're
transitioning out of a relationship
you're cutting it off you are breaking
up you're leaving you're quitting you're
getting a new dry cleaner whatever it is
be honest about the good stuff too
and steer clear of these grenade
comments like there was never anything
here anyway yes there was
i never liked you yeah you did
i never thought you did
it's okay to
no longer feel a certain way about
something
and not nuke the past
and if you're on the second thing is if
you're on the other end of this deal and
you're receiving some of this out of the
blue
just caustic grenades
rest knowing they're not true you're not
crazy
there was a connection there there was
some community there however weird or
twisted or sad or heartbreaking or
whatever it happened to be at that job
or whatever happened to be with your
yard person or whatever
you're not crazy there was something
there it's not anymore or maybe it is
and there's people just trying to amp
themselves up they're trying to flux
their way through this relationship but
you're not nuts and it's okay just to be
heartbroken for a season
the second thing is this
kids absorb tension
and i don't want us to forget that
that doesn't always mean you gotta end
your marriage this one in this
particular case um
if i remember correctly it's been a long
long time since we took this call but
jane was saying they had
they had been technically married for
four years but they were just best
friends um and they hadn't um
had a romantic relationship of any sort
they hadn't had anything other than a
good friend relationship in years she
knew it she wanted to be out of that
relationship and she realized she's just
choosing it
most people i don't
i'm not recommending you end anything
i'm recommending that
um
you take a good hard look at your
partner and say
we deserve better than this our kids
deserve better than this we could we
could choose joy other than yelling we
could choose
um to lean into laughter and intimacy
and starting all over and building a
relationship that is going to be great
for both of us we could both choose that
if we wanted to we could choose a house
where people chose
to be curious and chose laughter other
than yelling and slamming things
because your kids are absorbing every
single
second of it all of it
and i say this all the time and i'll
keep saying it
when kids feel that tension their bodies
react and their reaction may be adhd it
may be anxiety it may be depression it
may be any number of things their body
is going to try to solve that problem of
a chaotic household it's going to
respond the alarms are going to go off
and
the kids will be on a lifelong mission
to make mom and dad
okay and that will ultimately lead them
to make sure their
marriage partner's okay and their boss
is okay and their neighborhood's okay
and fill in the blank on and on and on
and on
stop it
choose peace for your home choose peace
for your heart choose peace for your
kids
and if you got a partner that just won't
play like no i choose anger i choose
yelling because i'm awesome whatever
i choose slamming things
[Music]
play this for them
sit down and say
i want to choose peace i want to choose
laughter i'm going to choose joy
and with all the chaos that's going on
in the world what better place
than inside of our homes
it's one of the last places on earth we
can actually choose to do anything
we can choose joy
[Music]
just takes a decision
[Music]
takes a partner
it takes a
here we go
[Music]
choose joy we'll be right back on the dr
john alone show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john deloney show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six-month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance i can't get off work and time
to go see somebody and it's way across
town what do i do cause i want help with
my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john daloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
deloney
and we're back all right so before we go
to aaron in sacramento i wanna let
everybody know this is a different
show today um this is a
yeah i'll just leave it at that leave it
this is a different show it's gonna hang
with us it's gonna be um incredible but
we're going to take this in a little bit
different direction than we normally go
aaron
this is delony how are you man
i'm doing pretty good doctor john how
are you
given the circumstances that's that's
pretty incredible man
well i'll have to give you an update at
some point but uh yeah given the
circumstances it's been the worst month
of my life yeah absolutely
so um
for the listener and for you um you oh
this is your story to tell and so um i'd
love to you hop in here whenever uh i
kelly let me know um
last week that you had reached out to us
and had had a
hurricane
and an atomic bomb and everything else
you can imagine go off inside your home
and you reached out wanted to
want to spend some time together and man
we cleared the whole deck and
this show is just going to be me and you
that's it and um i can recap what i know
or if you feel comfortable i'd love for
you to tell your story i know you've
rehashed this a million times um
in court and in the public and all
you know purchasing the pear tree but
if you're comfortable i'd love for you
to tell your story and give us an update
of where you're at and then how i can
help yeah sure yeah i can i can kind of
give you uh the backstory just in my own
words i haven't had to tell it in court
yet thank god but um
yeah so let's take you back four weeks
ago today um just a regular monday day i
was at work myself with my daughter i'm
a owner operator trucker so i have daddy
daughter day you know i have five kids
by the way um oldest is 17 my youngest
daughter is eight there's three boys in
between
16 13 and 10.
and my oldest boy was at college and so
my mom my mom my wife was home with my
three middle boys
and uh just a regular old monday nothing
was going on my wife was just sitting at
the dining room table in her house and
little did we know that my
my older two boys at home 16 and 13 year
old had premeditated
an attack on on my wife
and
carried out just out of nowhere um no
one saw any signs coming no one no one
would expected it
still is baffling four weeks later it
makes no sense
um but they did they they're in their
little minds their plan was to attack
mom and i think escape you know leave
the house take the van because the old
one has a driver's license and and leave
the state and who knows what they were
going to do but that was what was in
their mind
uh my older son took it upon himself i
don't think this was this was pretty
plain but he went into a murderous rage
and actually tried to kill my wife
and very nearly did
and they came at her with knives and a
baseball bat my oldest son had a
baseball bat
again unprovoked she was stabbed
quite a few times um she was being over
the head with a baseball bat my
ten-year-old who was not
in the same room her mom screamed and
came running to see what was going on i
went running for help
and he got taken down by my older son
with a baseball bat took a really really
bad
head injury
in the back of his head
and
it lasted about 45 minutes and you know
moved from different rooms a different
room my wife escaped to this and that
and
ended up in in our bedroom and
she ended up talking
getting my 16 year old to talk getting
the talk and getting the talk
and she started praying for everybody
and asked us for more time you know um
she thought her life was you know she
told me that she thought her life was
over
um and she just sort of you know asked
for some time to pray for him and she
started praying and
um
got him to talk and asked you know what
you know what he was planning on doing
and
why he was doing this and he was
murderous he he stayed it out right he
was planning on on murdering her and he
thought he had already killed my my
ten-year-old son turns out it wasn't
true
um he got her got him to talk got him
talk and eventually after 45 minutes or
so
he called 9-1-1
um
confessed to what had happened told him
my wife was hurt my son was hurt
and
they
told him to give the phone to my mom my
wife i keep doing it sorry that's okay
my wife
um
and uh and so 911 was on the phone with
my wife they put the weapons down went
outside and cooperated
deputies came
and they arrested my two sons
and they took my youngest son and my
wife to the emergency room
and
immediately went into surgery
life-threatening injuries both of them
um
i got wind of something funny going on
because my son actually sent a message
over the internet to a friend i still
don't even know who that is
who called our church who called me and
said hey i got this really funny message
about
you know your son and so i actually
raced home because i was only about a
half hour away and i couldn't get hold
of my life and i can't i showed up and
there was a dozen
deputies around my house
was closed
and
they wouldn't tell me what was going on
but i knew it was bad yeah you know
ask is anyone dead
i figured someone had to be dead for all
that and
thank god that wasn't quite the case but
it was close it was very very close
um so i don't know where you're going to
skip to from there but that's what
happened um so let's let's stop there
for a minute okay um
i
mean i don't have any words man
and you've you've obviously listened to
the show and you know that's a rare
moment
but i've had a word
um
but brother my heart's broken for you
yeah i didn't either i spent the
afternoon in that hospital both my wife
and my younger son were in emergency
surgery at two different hospitals by
the way which made it oh yeah oh
yeah just that i did a complications
down the road but
um i i just i was pacing around the
hospital not knowing
all i knew in the moment was my son was
completely not responsive his peoples
were dilated he had no response
whatsoever but they took him into
surgery and they you know he had
traumatic brain injury sure
and
but i knew my wife
going into surgery was
repeating my name and my phone number
over and over and over trying to get
them to call me so i knew what was going
on and so i i was hopeful that she
i knew she wasn't dead yeah
but i um when i got
when i got a debrief from the doctor
after like five hours of pacing the
hospital from about my son uh they
without using the words they basically
told me he was not gonna survive yeah
and they they lowered expectations they
said it's not good it's not good yeah um
they have some sort of scale they use
when they bring him to the hospital like
a one to fifteen for brain injuries
right he was a one he was a one wow
they had no hope that this kid would
survive
and so
first i mean
lord willing none of us are ever in this
situation
yeah um give
give people a a
some words about the disassociative
effects of you're just walking i mean
the lights are brighter and things feel
like you're in a video game or you're
not real walk people through just pacing
the hospital
um all the text messages start coming
through this is in the media this is all
over the place
it wasn't it wasn't that first day
first night you know not in the first
hours anyway you know that took a little
while okay
um you know in the first in the hospital
i'm pacing the hospital i got a hold of
my son that was in the college and the
the sheriff's uh
they had a pr person on site by the time
i got there he actually is in civilian
clothes he actually drove me to the
hospital and my daughter who's with me
that's great
and then he went and picked up my son so
the three of us
were at least together in the hospital
but
i had no idea what was going on i had no
idea what to tell my kids and
i felt like i should be sitting there
broken down crying but i wasn't i was
just kind of
i don't know which is one of my kind of
questions for you long term i still feel
kind of just numb up
weird yeah we'll get to those questions
so yeah
but in the moment it's just completely
numbing and it's just you know you don't
you don't plan for something like that
obviously no one does this is something
you read about on a you know in the news
or something and all of a sudden you're
in it
oh man
so
three or four weeks have gone by now
walk us through what the last three or
four weeks have been like
maybe the best three or four weeks of my
life
um
i mean i'll skip right to the end my
wife is out of the hospital we um wow
i didn't hadn't heard that man oh yeah
and my my son i'm in the hospital with
him right now i'm not with him in the
next room over but
um he's he's going to be discharged in
the next couple of days john
dude
yes it is absolutely a miracle no one
can really fathom
what has happened to
like i said i had faith my my wife would
make it out of this in some fashion but
i thought four weeks ago that i was
going to lose my son
and four weeks later they're literally
talking about discharging tomorrow or
not tomorrow wednesday what's his
cognitive capacity
amazing for where he is
he's walking he's talking he's eating i
mean they took the feeding tube out last
sun this last week because he spent the
whole week eating everything they would
put in front of his face he's got the
appetite of an amazing 10 year old
little boy 10 year old yeah
yeah
and can i have a snack a snack can i
have a snack yeah
i mean so the you know the last four
weeks for four weeks or sorry for a week
he spent completely sedated he was in
the picu the pediatric icu
at the children's hospital here and
completely sedated he had monitors
everywhere breathing tube feeding tube
the whole nine yards they were you know
drained out of his head for excess blood
just that whole thing you know
and after the first couple of days when
it was apparent he wasn't going to die
which that's what we all thought i mean
you know the nurses everything but after
a couple days the swelling wasn't
getting much worse and
it was looking like okay this is going
to be okay but
even at that point then there's you know
you
have no idea what this kid's life is
going to be like you don't know if he's
going to come back at all he might be
brain dead even if he comes back we were
getting warnings over and over from
nurses about how
i don't remember the terminology but
they had terms for
different kind of outbursts that they
would have or different personalities
that they would come back with sometimes
and
you know they were telling us this kid's
not going to be the same kid even if he
makes a recovery and they're looking at
six to nine months in the icu
and all of this stuff and so we spent
about a week there
and after a week
his body was good enough that they could
take the sedation completely down and
then he started to kind of wake up and
after a couple days he could kind of
communicate a little with his hands you
know he could give a thumbs up or he'd
get you know one finger for one two
finger no or so i wouldn't figure if he
has two finger for no kind of thing
and so he could communicate just little
bits like that and then you know week
and a half later i mean he was getting
better and better and every day the
doctors were just amazed they finally
took him out of the icu and moved him to
a regular hospital room because there
wasn't any need for that
level you know took him the breathing
tube out after a week and a half or so
and he was in the regular hospital room
and oh i got to add in just the whole
this whole coveting nonsense i mean i'm
in california dude it's crazy out here
still
and so they only let two people on the
visitor list total you can't change it
around it's not two at a time it's two
people total
and so it's been basically myself and my
mom his grandma are like the only two
people that have been able to see him
this entire time which is just crazy
yeah and as the whole emotional toll of
it all absolutely
but
um he was in that hotel room and i can't
tell you the excitement one morning i
was
my mom was up visiting with him in the
morning and i was gonna come and leave
her at some point and i got a text from
her saying uh when are you gonna be here
uh your son wants to know i thought that
was kind of a weird thing to say because
i was you know i definitely was
communicating ones and twos yeah and
this is like a week and a half ago i
came around the corner into his room and
he looked me dead in the eye and said hi
dad that was the first words i heard of
his mouth
man hey i'm smiling ear to ear too erin
i can hear you smiling on the phone now
that's amazing man it's been an amazing
recovery and
um
you know that's all good i mean there's
all the other stuff we're going to deal
with i guess in court and all that stuff
oh yeah yeah
so
the sun himself has just it's just been
amazing and like i said we're out of the
hospital a couple days here's walking
talking he's got to wear a helmet
because he's got a piece of his skull
still missing sure
um outside of that he he looks like he
talks a little slower than he used to
and he's got to think a little harder
but outside that he's the same kid that
i knew and loved four and a half weeks
ago absolutely man and some of that some
of that speech is
can be anesthetic related even and so
once you get him out and get him into
his own environment that
um that's dude that is incredible man
thank you for sharing that you just made
my whole day yeah absolutely so the
other side of that is is you've got two
kids who are in the court system for you
had some level of attempted murder
and they were arraigned they were
arraigned several weeks ago with both of
them two counts of attempted murder okay
is anybody being tried as an adult
uh my older son the state has declared
they are going to attempt to wow yes 16
yep jeez man
and so walk me through
the feelings you have on the other side
of this so you've you've got the
trauma of
i just may have lost my best friend and
partner and wife
yep and i may have lost my 10 year old
baby son
yep and
oh my gosh incredible they're safe and
now you've got this other side of this
conversation which is
yep
i've got two
two kids that tried to murder my my
family
yep so walk me through what's in your
heart mind there
it makes everything weird
they've appointed special lawyers that
are not um
the public defenders because of the
circumstances with you know i and my
wife are victims and parents at the same
time so it makes the whole legal system
weird when i'm talking to detectives
sometimes they're talking to me as the
parent and sometimes they're talking to
me as the you know
father of the accused as a victim yeah
yeah yeah and
and so you you gotta walk that line but
um i mean long story short they like i
said they both got arraigned in court
there there's definitely a an aggressor
and a follower situation going on
between the two of them but in the eyes
of the law they both participated in
some fashion yeah
and so they're both guilty of of
attempted murder and i mean thank god
for them it's it's as little as that you
know given how how brutal it was good
man ma'am i've met with uh
both of myself i'm the only one that's
gotten in front of them other than
lawyers
and other counselors
that are in the juvie system
and that's tough i mean you sit in front
of them and tell me about your
conversation with your 16 year old
that one is difficult i've only got in
front of him once i was gonna get in
front of him here in a couple of days
again but
they wouldn't let me see him for a
couple of weeks given the weirdness of
the situation but they finally did a
couple weeks ago and
he was very
um reserved
i don't i i've been thinking about how
to put this
because
i don't i don't know the the
psychological mental illness world but i
i do think in conversations with a
couple people that have met with him in
the juvia system
there may be a burdening
mental illness of some kind going on
with him we don't know obviously hasn't
been diagnosed and i don't want to put
anything in his mind that's not there
sure but in in speaking with him in
person
um i mean he did meet with me he didn't
refuse um but he was very reserved very
down he said he regretted what had
happened
um but he
he was so it looked like depression i
mean it looked like a kid that was
depressed and understandably so sure at
this point
his life as he knew it was over yeah
yeah yeah and he had so much going for
him but
he
just the look in his face you know just
showed
the depression he's a ghost yeah
yeah and out in hearing my wife tell the
story of that day i don't know if it was
some sort of i mean i've heard the term
manika pack i don't know if there's any
media going on in that moment but it was
such a high and low between the when
that thing started and when it ended
that day
and then i'm looking at him now and he's
he's not that kid that could do
something like that you know yeah he
just looks depressed and down he says he
regrets it he's not
sure what to do obviously he's a 16 year
old kid he's a kid yeah yeah and i don't
know what to do with him either i'm not
i've never had to deal with courts and
judges and all this stuff yeah
not my world
well dude um as we get into what we do
next
thank number one thanks for telling your
story and for unpacking that i know
that's a
horrible story we could probably spend
another few days together talking about
your other two kids you got a younger
daughter who was with you who just lost
everything and you've got an older child
who's in college just lost everything
and
um
you are dad at the epicenter here having
to hold all this stuff together the two
kids who are in the court system now who
you so badly want to love and believe in
and who also tried to murder your wife
and you've got your
recovering
two traumatic brain injuries in your
home one of which is
the other
i would say half but let's be real um
you're a truck driver so she's the other
85 of you know the person who runs the
house and
then you got two other little kids who
if they had friends that this had gone
through you'd be there for them because
it'd be traumatic and it's in their own
house and so
here you are in the middle
holding a
unspooled sweater just a pile of string
man so i feel like it i feel like i am
in the middle of everything i'm the dad
i'm the husband i'm the father i'm the
you are one of the grandparents that are
there i'm the you know i'm the point of
contact for the police for the lawyers
for everything you are man so
let's take some time dude um
you're still in this you said it best
you haven't you haven't just fallen
apart you haven't cried and there's that
weird meta moment that starts happening
thinking huh i would have thought if my
kids were
incarcerated or i would have thought if
my wife was almost gonna was was almost
about to leave us that i would act this
way but my body's acting that way right
so you have this almost right
meta disassociative you start talking to
yourself in the voice behind the voice
right like what's actually happening
right
and then there's those weird nights you
just go home and
like i'm just gonna turn on the office
and it's this like you're here but
you're not here right
um so dude any questions you want to ask
i'll go there with you
okay
i don't
i don't know it is that weird feeling of
being in the middle you you know i don't
i don't watch the office but i sit
around playing stupid video poker for
hours in the evening just whittling away
time when i when i have my own time you
know
yeah that's my that's my my my numbing
agent i guess it's just just killing
random time staying up way too late and
i'm i don't sleep because you know
everyone yells at me about getting
enough sleep and eating and
easier said than done oh yes yes yes so
for whatever it's worth you get a pass
for a few days okay cool good
okay
we get a pass all right so man let's
let's do this any tell me what's on your
heart and mind and how i can how i can
help
again i don't even know john i
i guess i guess
i need i need a little help on just all
these different all these different
pieces i got my wife that i can't really
even share everything with you know
with the family i i can't really talk to
her about my older sons you know yeah
it's like but i can talk to her about my
younger son that is recovering so
amazingly we talk about him all the time
and you know my
my
you mentioned my 17 and my younger
daughter that they're probably the
easiest going about this whole thing
because they're somewhat removed from it
they weren't there right and my oldest
son can go back to college my youngest
daughter is
with family just kind of removed from
the situation playing with cousins all
the time you know she's good um
i i
have to talk to different people about
different aspects of it it feels so
bifurcated and you know i can talk to
the
detectives about my son but i gotta be
careful what i say because i want to you
know add fuel to the fire that you know
could
put them in jail longer but same time
maybe i want them in jail laundry
because they tried to kill my wife and
right i feel just very torn apart in all
these different ways
and
so i just i kind of try to ignore a lot
of it you know i don't try not to think
about all those disabilities but
associative pieces you know yeah
so
here's a couple things i'll give you to
walk through it and then you stop me and
ask any question any time okay okay
so
number one
is
you gotta have
one two five nine people they're gonna
walk through this thing with you
and i want you to think of this as
you're the quarterback now for
everything and you got to have an
offensive coordinator defensive
coordinator and a head coach somewhere
who are those people for you
rattle them off for me
oh
i mean i'm probably my best friend but
he's not in the area okay i called him
in the middle night the other night um
my cousin growing up
um he's a guy that i can just call and
talk to if i ever need just to
talk about random stuff like that okay i
have a a neighbor that
was a um
oh shoot what do you i don't know him
well but he was a counselor for 20 years
in the
dealing with trauma and aaron counselors
are the worst stay away from those men
no that's great
i just don't know him very well i guess
it's a weird thing you know sure i don't
know if it's a good thing though if i
don't if it's if i'm talking to someone
about this
nonsense that i don't
have a relationship with really outside
of you know friendly banter yeah
how about work
are you still having i mean obviously
you're trying to go to work every day to
pay the bills huh
i haven't been to work in a month man
okay are they taking care of you or are
you did you just
live on the credit card i haven't i
haven't made the dollar but you know we
we put out a good find me page and raise
a little bit of money and people have
been very generous with their time and
with meals and stuff so do you have a
church community you're connected to or
absolutely okay absolutely
i've been getting a lot of input from
our lead pastor and we have a church
that
loves us and we'll absolutely take care
of we've been there for 20 or 18 years
so fantastic cool so here's what i want
you to do
when you get out a piece of paper
and i want you to come up with who your
offensive coordinator defensive
coordinator and head coach is going to
be
and you're not really going to offense i
want a defense on the other but i'm
thinking
i need somebody to help quarterback my
home
help take care of this house are there
going to be meals here or the is the
light bill gonna be paid
um in mo in days when i'm gonna have to
be in court and someone has to help my
wife go to the bathroom whatever those
realities are gonna be for you with two
people with traumatic brain injuries
um
is there somebody you can sit down with
or two people or three people or a
couple
like a husband a wife team or something
you can look across the table from and
say
over the next 60 days i'm gonna need you
guys to step into my life i'd like to
invite you into that
and that might be a couple at church
that you've known for a long time and
you've never been that specific but
here's the the meta here is you've got
to sit down and make your needs known
and risk asking somebody for help
okay okay
and then i want you to get whether it's
your own attorney whether it's an
attorney at church somebody you know
somebody that's gonna help you
understand the legal jargon both your
kids i'm sure got different attorneys if
they're going to try one as an adult my
guess is they is that right they got
different ones they're different yep
yeah dude and at some weird moment you
nailed it you're going to have to sit by
your kids because they're minors and
they can't make decisions on their own
and you're the you're the victim right
you're on the other side of the table
and this is gonna cause some major
tension in your marriage
and it's gonna you're gonna have to have
some somebody be with you at all of
these meetings if possible and that
might be your dad it might be your mom
it might be
a friend who's just like man i'm all in
on this on with you
if you don't
and that can't happen take a recorder
with you so you can record these
meetings because what's going to happen
is you're going to start running
together on you're going to think this
one that that one and that one i thought
i was talking to this lawyer
and uh that was actually my kid's
teacher it's going to start jumbling up
in your head okay
okay and you were probably i would i'd
be willing to my truck's not very nice
i'd be willing to bet my truck right now
you are still in some sort of shock your
body has taken over for your brain
okay
that will slowly start to you can't do
it for long your brain your body can't
do that long term it will start to take
back it'll start to recede and those
feelings you're talking about that rage
that anger that those tears you're gonna
be sitting there playing
playing video games one night you should
start crying
that will come
it will come in heavy waves and so
having your best friend on letting them
know i'm gonna call you at crazy moments
okay
please answer your phone
um and it might be i'm gonna call you
and just
let a string of expletives go that maybe
have never been put together on the face
of the earth but they're gonna come out
of my mouth and i need somebody else to
hear that because grief demands a
witness and they'll say you're good and
you'll be like yep just need to get that
out and it's 3am and they're going to
hang up and everybody's going to go back
to sleep
or it may be
they just ask me
um if my son xy and z and i know he did
that
or i know he's got a journal or i know
his passcode to his phone and the dad in
me wants to say i don't know where that
is
because i know what's on there
and the truth is i need to i need to put
that out there because he hurts somebody
he could hurt somebody again
and i need you to walk alongside with me
and make sure that i make ethical
right decisions
not emotional dad decisions
okay and have somebody that's gonna walk
so i'm just i'm those are just a few
examples
long story short you're gonna have to
have people in your life that you
assigned to a post and that will walk
through you walk through this with you
yeah okay i think i i think i have a lot
of that it just feels like it's so many
different it is it is people that's why
i want you to have a head coach somebody
that will come over and this might be
your dad it might be your mom it might
be your pastor it might be an attorney
friend at church it might be anybody a
mechanic friend of church who will sit
down with you and this is number two on
a piece of paper you got to map this
thing out you know like my buddy dave
ramsey talks about you know you gotta
make a budget here's all the debts i
have i gotta write them out and look at
them on a piece of paper that's what
you've gotta do here you got too much
going on
all right go to target or go to walmart
get a a folder that you can have and put
every kid you have's name on it and your
spouse you're gonna start getting
medical bills out the wazoo you're gonna
get legal stuff you're gonna have to be
here at this place and there in that
place it's just gonna the paperwork and
the stuff and the little jargon
you're gonna have to have an
organization um this your origins have
to be top-notch so start that at the
front end of this thing okay
all the paperwork's sitting in a big
pile in my life i know it is like i know
it is man that's what i'm telling you go
get a folder because what's going to
happen in four months someone's going to
say hey i need such and such paper what
did you say when you talked to such and
such person on this day what did you say
and you could be like dude i don't even
know what day it was that day
i want you to have a file folder full of
all the paperwork
neatly filed it's gonna help you sleep
okay
i also want you to have a journal of
some sort it can be five dollars or ten
bucks that you get at walmart that just
says i talked to detective so and so at
this time on this day about this
and in six months in two years and seven
years when this stuff is still in court
or your kid comes up for parole or
whatever happens you're going to want to
look back and say here's what this was
about
all right and what i'm telling you is if
the if you've got piles of paper
everywhere and you talk to this
detective and you talk to that doctor
and this bill collector and then your
boss is like hey are you going to run a
route or what
your brain is going to go hyperactive on
you and when it goes hyperactive you're
not going to sleep at night and you
don't sleep at night you're going to
start getting really anxious you're
going to start slipping in your own
depression and so what i want you to do
is to
keep your environment spotless
okay stay as or this may be the first
time you've ever been organized in your
life and this is this is the season okay
i'm gonna take a chapter for my wife on
that one because she was the organized
organized person in our family you know
what she's gonna be so proud of you
she's gonna be so proud and if you suck
at this
and this is me talking to the mirror
here
ask somebody that is a friend of yours
who's a church someone at your church
someone that's your neighbor
say i am terrible at organization i'd
really love if someone could make it
could come by once or twice a week and
help me with this
and you will have people line up to
support you who want to help want to
love you and they don't know how and
they're great at organization but man
they're thinking this guy's dealing with
in fact he almost lost two family
members
boom they're like i can do that somebody
can help with a meal train somebody can
so that you don't have to worry about
meals for the next 30 days
people want to help but they need
clarity and that's where you can really
help yourself and then by giving people
jobs and direction okay
yeah we've gotten that out
outpouring of support with like meals
and stuff but you're right about the
clarity that i've just been trying to
let it kind of happen and that's right
take a look and take ownership of it
okay yeah if i ask for something
specific it usually happens but i just
don't
i don't ask enough for what exactly
i or we may need in a moment so that's
the third thing here okay we've talked
about getting people in your life we've
talked about organization
the third one is going to be grief and
you are going to have i need you to hear
me very clearly
the life that you knew is now over with
a period at the end
okay
i think i know that i know you i know
and
most people don't have the courage to
say that out loud to someone they love
and so i'm telling you as my new friend
there's a period at the end of that
sentence
and a lot of grief gets hung up because
people want to go back to life before
the affair they want to go back to the
way things were before i gained this
weight or before we had kids or before
whatever the thing is
and we spend so much time trying to get
back to the past instead of building a
new future
and so i want you because the temptation
is if i can just get these kids like the
right psychologist and then we can all
get back home and get my my 10 year old
healed up and get my wife back then we
can get back to this thing and we're
just gonna go back to
your life before this is now over
okay
okay
everything forward is you building
something new
and that's should be both terrifying
it is terrifying and scary
and it should also give you direction
okay
every time you think about yeah but it
used to
you can stop and go
that part's over now
now i am going to have the opportunity
to rebuild my marriage
and my wife's gonna have a lot of
healing here's what healing's gonna look
like for your wife
what did i miss what was it about me
that my kids did this
how could i create kids and grow kids
that that kind of stuff is gonna unspool
and unspool and you're gonna go through
that too
so when i talk about you're going to get
a different wife you're going to get it
you're going to become a different
husband
it's not that your psychology is going
to be different it's that y'all are
going to be asking yourselves hard
questions about what happened in our
home
and those rattle people in their core as
they should right
yeah they're difficult questions to come
face to face with for sure and they're
not going to have real good answers
no there's no answers that's going to be
satisfactory absolutely and everybody
deals with ambiguity differently or
that's just what happened
or maybe you're gonna find a journal or
a bunch of social media stuff or a bunch
of oh my gosh i could i we missed xy
whatever the things are that come out
or
it may have just been totally random
and few things are scarier than random
right
right it'd be a lot easier if we could
point back to some abuse or to something
oh my gosh my kid just woke up and
decided to do this
i almost lost my 10 year old
um
so i want you to be hyper intentional
about every time you start to lean back
into it we just need to get back to
that part so you do need to you do need
to ask those questions right i mean that
is
for sure you'd be a psychopath if you
didn't answer those questions ask those
questions
if you're not plagued with
why and what were you doing and how and
what was it about
absolutely
absolutely you gotta ask those questions
and that brings me to the final thing
here number four okay
and again i'm just pulling this off top
of my head i didn't know where this
conversation was gonna go
you my brother aaron have to take care
of aaron
and your temptation over the next six
months over the next two years is going
to be to make sure everybody else in
your world is okay
and it's going to come at your cost
it's what i'm telling you is i want you
to never forget this
the best way you can make sure
everybody's okay is if erin's okay
and that means you may have to get
serious about your physical health for
the first time ever
is that fair
yeah that's fair yeah
you got to start lifting weights and
going on a walk
you're going to have to be intentional
about what you eat
because when i get stressed dude there's
a special aisle in the grocery store and
it's just covered in gummy candies and
chocolate and shenanigans it's
incredible
right you got to be intentional about
what you eat you have to pay attention
about going to sleep
you're going to have to be intentional
about getting a counselor you've got a
couple years of work ahead of you at at
least okay
yeah it's kind of a long road it is i've
been relying on my my wife to keep me in
the healthy with the eating aspect of
our relationship for our entire marriage
basically yep and now you're in the
driver's seat
there you there you go that's right
and it's okay to feel
angry
it's okay to feel heartbroken it's okay
to
not be able to get out of bed for a
couple of days
and that's when you're gonna call on
your friends and say hey i need someone
to pick up so and so from school i can't
move today
grief is gonna look different for
everybody
and you get to grieve how you need to
grieve
but you got to be intentional about
taking care of yourself okay
i think i can work to that
i know you can and i also know you're on
autopilot right now so here's the the
last the thing i want to ask you of okay
okay
in two weeks
in four weeks and five weeks i want you
to call me back and we'll have you back
on
and
i want you to let me know where you are
and it may be a season of man people are
healthy things are good it may be you
are in a black hole of despair and i
want you to give us a shout okay
yeah i can do that and i'm gonna ask you
who's walking with you
are you being intentional about taking
care of yourself
do you have a plan of grieving this
and do you have some organization going
for you okay
okay
and last last last thing
okay
your oldest and your youngest
don't lose them in this process okay no
i'm worried about them to be honest yeah
i told you earlier in this conversation
they're doing the best just because
they're kind of removed from it and i
did that somewhat intentionally my
oldest son we had
i pulled him into it
for a week or so but after he can't go
visit his mom he can't go visit his son
because of all the covety stuff
he's not he's kind of a weight to me so
i told him go back to school go back to
work you know
there's not a whole lot you can do and
he's um
he he's doing good he's a stoic
character and my my daughter she's
removed from it and she's happy-go-lucky
but i'm a little worried that that goes
on too long and they just kind of
disappear into
whatever they're going to disappear into
i've kind of lost track a little bit of
yeah of both of them you know do they
does your um oldest who's in college
live around you in any any shape form or
fashion well he still lives with us okay
great okay so here's the deal i mean
here's how you can do this okay every
week in your calendar this is part of
your organization you get a calendar too
i want you to plan a meal with each one
of them by yourself
okay
okay when you and this will be in the
season when you can't get out of bed
this will help you get out of bed
and in a season when
they
are so heartbroken but they're scared to
call you because they know you're
heartbroken too this will put i you'll
get to put eyes on them
so i want you to let them know from this
point you can tell them from now until
for the foreseeable future
you and me are going to breakfast every
tuesday morning
build your school schedule around it
build your work skills we are not going
to miss this time
together and that's when you're gonna
ask questions like how are you feeling
how are you doing how's your heart
are you angry are you pissed off are you
heartbroken all those things and you're
gonna get all that and i want you to
take your daughter out
okay
they need to see and touch dad
because everything in their world is
unanchored now
yeah and by them seeing you
you're gonna see them
and you're gonna get anchored in too
okay
i like that idea my son and i my older
oldest son and i we went to church just
the two of us for the last few weeks
um and uh we went out to lunch after
church
two weeks in a row and we kind of gave
it up but
back on for the next eight years just
put it in there man you got a long road
ahead of you
yeah all right aaron
i'm gonna let you go okay
thank you so much for your call brother
and we're so happy that your wife and
son are coming home that's incredible
and we will be
thinking about you guys from afar as you
go through the court process as your
family heals and as you create a new
tomorrow
keep in touch here and we'll be thinking
about you my brother we'll be right back
on the dr john delaney show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndalone.com and get
your copy of redefining anxiety today
all right we are back
i want to get an email here
from caitlin
caitlyn writes
since reading your book recommendations
solve for happy so
mo gadot g-a-w-d-a-t if you haven't read
solve for happy it's an extraordinary
read
um please pick it up
i've realized that my brain chowder
chowder good reading deloney i realize
that my brain chatter is loud and often
happens when i'm not realizing it
my husband's mind is apparently blank
most days
awesome
it's not but that was awesome when you
wrote that
what are ways i can achieve peace and
quiet in my mind to help me live in the
moment
i'm aware of meditation but i'm looking
for more options during the day when my
mind sneaks up on me
so
great question caitlyn great question
um you might heard it said monkey brain
or monkey mind or
um
uh
there's a thousand different ways you
talk about brains rumination that just
spins and spins and spins the way i've
seen rumination happen is
um
either folks have imaginary
conversations over and over and over in
their heads you know what i mean like
with people that you're never gonna have
this conversation but it just goes over
if i man if i see them i'm gonna tell it
no you're not you're not gonna actually
have that conversation or if that guy
walks up to me in the bar i'm gonna tell
him you're not you're not gonna actually
say that but we
go and go and go and go and go and we
spin ourselves up we get our bodies all
wound up
and then we try to solve that wind up
with i'm just gonna tell them this and
this and i'm gonna quit i'm gonna go get
another job and i'll make seven figures
i'm none of that stuff's real
the other
rumination is
the catastro
catastrophizing right
well then if this happens then
you know if there's a an economic
correction or downturn then
everyone's going to try to cash all
their money out and then we're not going
to have any money and money's not even
real and what are we doing we should be
i know bitcoin or i'm going to buy meat
and wood and cigarettes and coffee
and then it's i'm going to we're gonna
have an ax
i know we need bullets
lots of bullets we'll trade those for
water and dogs
whatever
we start catastrophizing or the third
one is those are the two big ones the
third one is just going all day long
hey what about this what about that hey
look at those clothes once i got driving
like that it just goes and goes and goes
and goes it goes and we never even
stopped to think
what are you doing stop talking shh be
quiet
and i'm speaking from first-hand
knowledge here because i have a brain
that never
stops
so
here are some things i have done over
time that have really helped me
meditation the reason meditation is good
is it's practice
it is practicing
gently taking control of that monkey
mind the one that just goes it goes it
goes it goes and goes the chatter the
chatter chatter chatter chatter chatter
and so i meditation has worked wonders
for me it's something i do regularly and
i've done for years and years and years
and years
but also
recently i've tried something that
doesn't involve
meditation it involves being intentional
so here's what i've i've come to learn
that our bodies get addicted
to
our stress response it's a chemical
addiction it's a perception addiction
so when i say addiction i mean just like
nicotine just like alcohol our bodies
get addicted to it
and when things are going okay
when we're just driving to work or we're
just walking home from work or we're
just sitting down on the couch next to
our husband here or our wife or whatever
our body wants a hit
or i hear that in the shower like people
tell me that this happens in the shower
a lot when their brains just go bananas
our brain wants a hit of that stress
response of those stress response
chemicals and so what it does is it
notifies our frontal lobe
alert and it spins up a conversation it
spins up anxiety it spins up a story
that then our body can go ah stress
response let's solve this thing and it
kicks it all up and now we're in a fight
that only we can solve through our
clever one-liners that we're never gonna
say through our mic drop moments
or through catastrophizing future
planning okay so what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna build a bunker and in the
bunker i'm gonna have 18 years of canned
foods and then i'm gonna have a gun so i
can shoot my neighbor for their water
whatever
it feels like productive thinking it's
not it's a fantasy it's not real
how do you stop it what i've started to
do is when i feel my body spin up
or
when i find my i catch myself just
having these
mindless
non-stop go go go go go go go
i will say the words stop
what are we solving for
and i will get quiet for a second
and i will ask my body what are we
solving for here
usually
it is
i have to have a hard conversation with
somebody
or i just got some scary news about the
economy about health about physical
health about my kids at school whatever
the thing may be
it's usually my body just trying to
reach out and scan the universe for some
fantasy solution to some real problem
i'm having
and so what i'll do is i'll stop and say
what are we solving for here and if it
is i really have to have this
conversation with somebody then i will
go write it down i'll get out of the
shower i'll dry off i'll get a pad of
paper and i will write down here's a
conversation i need to have
here is what is going on
right with my radio show here's what's
going wrong with it and it's not james
faults probably kelly's fault
probably
i'll write down these things that i've
got concerns about and i will stop and i
will let my body
i won't just run off with it and
sometimes this takes five minutes that's
it sometimes takes 15 minutes i was on a
plane the other night flying back from
vegas to after a speaking gig and it
took me about an hour to just type all
this stuff out
what is what are you doing what are we
solving for here
what i've tried to do over and over is
what meditation does is any sort of
intentional thought work is
what are we doing what are we doing what
are we solving for what are we trying to
solve for what relationship is
dysfunctional here
and what i'm finding in short order
that when i take back control of my
thoughts
back control of my mind
it goes ah we're good okay and it
literally will quiet itself
i had a weird moment on the plane after
i spent some time writing that out
when i just sat there
i broke my headphones that's a whole
other story i broke my headphones i had
nothing i'm just sitting on the plane
and my brain didn't take off on me it
was just
peaceful and i would need you to know as
an ocd guy as an anxious guy i don't
experience that very often but i've been
practicing hard at it catching myself
catching myself catching myself
here's another thing that's really
important i've learned that when i load
up on caffeine when i load up on sugar
when i don't exercise i have less
control of my thoughts i have less
control of my brain spinning out on me
or when it does spin out on me and i
recognize it i have less motivation to
sit down and write out my thoughts i'm
like whatever dude this sucks i'm gonna
go grab a bag of gummy candy or whatever
and so take care of your body
be intentional about going for a walk
being intentional about
taking cold showers don't sit there for
11 hours taking a hot shower that's what
my brain spins off on me be intentional
about taking care of your body
have human connection around you
and your brain feels safe it doesn't
feel like it has to solve everything and
when it does spin out on you and it's
not because you're tired or because
you're just eating trash all day or
because you're on coffee number 14.
write them down
ask your body what are we solving here
and then the magic is reach out and let
somebody know have that hard
conversation and if it's not safe to
have that hard conversation because
you're an abusive relationship that
person is going to fire you go to
somebody that you can talk to about it
go to something you can talk to about it
and
last little piece
caitlyn here
my husband's mind is apparently blank
most days
it's not
a blank mind or a person who just sits
there flipping channels or playing video
games their brain is doing the other
thing
it's not fighting it's not running it's
frozen
it goes
i can't handle this stress you're a lot
so i'm out
bye
and it unplugs
that person has to practice plugging in
practice
having conversations practice what is
your body feeling right now it's
actually feeling nothing why
life is fun life should be full of joy
you can look for beauty what do you what
does your body freezing from
so it's the same exact process just the
other way
okay
same process just the other way
caitlyn here's the magic you can learn
to control your thoughts
and when you find yourself having
chattered up your mind for an hour two
hours don't be mad be curious
what are you doing
what are we solving for why are you
having this conversation 45 times call
your boss call him i can't call my boss
not safe cool call your friend let him
know i hate my job it sucks i need to
find a new one cool go do that
call my friend ken coleman get a new one
i'm burnt down i'm fried call my friend
christy wright she'll help you out
whatever the thing is
write it down what are we solving for
here
you can control your thoughts all right
as you wrap up today's show one of my
favorite songs of all time
written by his wife june and merle
kilgore
but johnny made it famous joining
ring of fire and it goes like this love
is a burning thing how do you can't not
sing it
and it makes
fiery ring social distortions version of
this incredible
bound by wild desire i fell into a ring
of fire
i fell into a burning ring of fire we
already said that we're gonna say it
again i went down down down and the
flames went higher and this is the part
that could be a preparation h commercial
and it burns burns burns the ring of
fire
the ring of fire see you next time on
the dr john dolone show